today Sandra Bullock's got a lot of
credits to her name including
world-wide-web
Pioneer oops et was with Miss
Congeniality herself as she became the
first person ever to buy a movie ticket
online more inescapable when she finds
records are alive at least there's the
auger and while Sandy might have played
a computer expert in the movie she was
still learning the ropes in real life
click for Showtime two tickets for this
movie okay so where's your delete here I
think I should entered something wrong
no it's okay see you know it's amazing I
just I just want to make a little point
here that modern technology I'm just
reading my stuff today and to bring me
down there if I click on the net okay
yeah neighborhood okay what Jenny when
go to build your ticket order you have
selected the 10:20 show for the net at
the Hollywood galaxy six 7021 Hollywood
Boulevard suite 200 Hollywood on Friday
728 95 now please follow these four
steps one select the number of tickets
you need one dollar search hard to
protect it all right yeah
well you know what it doesn't do it
doesn't verify that you've typed in the
wrong number it says your number is and
then you should have double verification
just a little something that I thought
might help you could do it now after
you've done the numbers we have to press
this button to send our order and here
we go so I'm gonna think I'm gonna cry
you're the first one you're the first
one you know why pay for it yeah you
must remain on this page stay online
until you receive a confirmation of your
order I know I told you I got a little
misty is a nice movie about computers
that try to destroy how is it a friendly
service it took my money didn't it but
you always do I mean did you notice how
neurotic I became when I started
punching the number so um these things
are nice it's very nice to have this is
great but anything where I have to punch
in my credit cards always a little scary
so make sure you punch in the correct
number just like the poster it's got
nose in the mouth and the one eye you
guys what about what about other movies
that already came out you could look at
those too hard by the main menu you go
back going to W okay she wants to see
why do you write yeah I just want to see
if it's safe you'll get it hey check
make sure I'm covered everywhere
I think maybe we should see that it's a
delightful film today buying tickets to
the movies online and through apps is
the norm and we have sandy to thank for
paving the way across the worldwide web
[Music]